hey guys let's talk about a hair loss
now it's normal for guys to start losing
their hair in their thirties mid
thirties but some of you might be losing
a lot more hair because of your bad
habits and you don't even realize it
so in this video I'm gonna talk about
five bad habits causes you to lose your
hair let's get to it
I have a dream so good if you're new
here to my channel I'm Daniel and
welcome to D LM model lifestyle now
let's start with the first bad habit
it causes hair loss
hot showers I used to be guilty in this
one and why is hot showers so bad for
your hair because hot water dehydrates
your hair leaving it dry and brittle so
it breaks and folds out easier when you
wash it and also when you dry it and
style it later on it also dries your
scalp when you wash your hair and strip
your hair of its necessary oils I know
shower hours are nice now I can
sometimes I still make it hot but I just
don't keep my hair underneath the shower
it's not that good for my body but
sometimes I'll make the sacrifice I'm
not saying you have to your choice
poor diet and also skipping meals if you
have a bad nutritional lifestyle it's
not only gonna affect your whole body
but your hair as well and listen up your
hair needs more than McDonald's so to
keep your hair healthy eat more fruits
and vegetables like bananas and
cauliflower and even egg yolk because it
contains natural biotin which is a
vitamin D that improves the
infrastructure of your hair and increase
hair growth site hairstyles if you like
tighter hairstyles you're probably more
likely to lose your hair it greatly
damages your hair follicles and once
it's badly damaged is almost impossible
for your hair to grow back again so
don't style your hair that high just
give it a little bit of freedom
now the next habit is one that I can't
really control it is using excessive
hair styling products now for me in
modeling over the last 13 years oh my
goodness
especially in the last few years here in
Asia some of you who watched my model
lifestyle series you know that I've been
doing modeling contract in Asia just to
get the experience of the culture but
they use so many styling products
excessively on my hair that it damages
my hair in there's been times where I
have to take just a break from modeling
for a few weeks
even now I'm in Japan you can see the
front of my hair here some of the hair
are broken so please from personal
experience stop using excessive hair
styling products alright this last one
is very interesting it might come to a
surprise to a lot of you but if you use
certain medications like antidepressants
and anti-anxiety agents and even
hormones like thyroid replacement drugs
they can cause you to lose your hair and
for women birth control pills can also
interfere with your hair growth causing
it to fall out prematurely now if you've
got some time check out some more of my
videos and we will talk soon Cheers
you